you had twice as many followers now you
got 2 million followers five minutes
whatever it doesn't do anything it's
called the hedonic treadmill like once
you get to a certain level it takes a
lot more you know changed and followers
money impact women whatever you want to
make you have one more quanta of
Happiness right on the other hand this
is a concept from entropy I could make
your life miserable in an infinite
number of ways there's more space space
to make your life unhappy than happy so
it's sort of like that what you should
be doing in life is doing that which
will cause you Devastation if it goes
away because those are the things like
are where you're reducing entropy like a
kid like how to make your life a billion
times worse but there's no way to make
your life a billion times better you can
never be happy you can only become happy
Kurt Vonnegut said if this isn't
goodness if this isn't happiness nothing
is just remind yourself how awesome it
is every breath everything that you do
when you make an impact even some of the
bad stuff that happens